[Music]
do you think we'll ever create an AI
system that we can love and loves us
back and a deep meaningful way like in
the movie her
I think AI will be capable of convincing
you to fall in love with it very well
and that's different than us humans you
know we start getting into a
metaphysical question of like do
emotions and thoughts exist in a
different realm the physical and maybe
they do maybe they don't
I don't know but but from a physics
standpoint I didn't think I tend to
think of things you know like physics
was my main sort of training and and for
a physics standpoint essentially if it
loves you in a way that is that you
can't tell whether it's real or not
it is real that's a physics view of love
yeah if there's no if you if you cannot
just if you can't prove that it does not
if there's no test that you can apply
that would make it
may allow you to tell the difference
then there is no difference right and
it's similar to seeing our world of
simulation there may not be a test to
tell the difference between what the
real world simulation and therefore from
a physics perspective it might as well
be the same thing yes and there may be
ways to test whether it's a simulation
there might be I'm not saying there
aren't but you could certainly imagine
that a simulation could correct that
once an entity in the simulation found a
way to detect the simulation it could
either restart the you know pause the
simulation start a new simulation or do
one of many other things that then
corrects for that error
you